[Musique]
à bord ss colombie 1er décembre 1940
depuis ce matin c'est la route vers les
médias pour le plaisir pour la 13e
édition accueille toujours cinq artistes
femmes qui ne se connaissent pas qui se
rencontrent et qui crée un spectacle de
lecture expressive et cette année avec
de la danse avec du chant avec des
parties
on va dire dramatique toujours à partir
des différents textes de zobel également
des lettres qu'il a écrit à certaines
personnes donc c'est tout un mélange de
ce qu'il est que nous voulons
représenter mon fils voulons est mort je
ne le vois plus je n'entends plus avoir
je pense à lui et marc est de penser
pour retrouver sa voix et son visage
ça me fait mal
j'en pleurerais encore comme un enfant
qui pleure on ne sait pas pourquoi c'est
dans mon coeur que pleurent le mal si
fort que pas une larme le sort de mes
yeux j'ai tout frais de pas ouvrir la
vanne qui retient les pleurs je me pèse
il ne peut plus dire une conteuse et
apolline siwa qui est également conteuse
et comédienne et il y a aussi une
danseuse
il y a aussi fait de la danseuse et
florine cas qui vient de montpellier
il y a inna boulanger qui est danseuse
et comédienne
il y a caroline savard qui vient de
québec qui est comédienne également
et puis il ya aussi and alex psyché
quitte avec nous pour la première fois
dans ce que nous faisons